in America if you have enough influence
you will never get sent to prison
like this guy from The Dupont family
that our worded his own daughter and if
for some reason you do get sent to
prison because you weren't able to buy
off the judge or something you're not
going to be staying in prison for very
long
but what happens if you have money but
you don't have influence what if you're
a rich guy that the powers that be don't
like a rich guy like Jordan Belfort the
real Wolf of Wall Street if you remember
from the movie Jordan Belfort made his
money by screwing over rich people by
selling them penny stocks he wasn't
screwing over poor people and that was
his fatal mistake you see there were
plenty of people committing the same
exact crime as Jordan Belfort except he
was the only one doing it against the
rich and that was his downfall he didn't
have influence no he was screwing over
the people with the influence he was
screwing over people that were connected
with the politicians the justice system
and that's why he got taken down but
lucky for him Jordan belfer still had
money so he didn't have to stay in the
regular prison with a mere peasants no
he was able to stay in a luxury prison
that's seen at the end of The Wolf of
Wall Street movie of him enjoying tennis
in a prison that looks like a country
club yeah that was not an exaggeration
Jordan Belfort described prison as quote
a boys club and quote totally Mello he
had Tommy Chong from Cheech and Chong as
his bunk mate when I went into jail my
bunk'd made turned out was Tommy Chong
from Cheech and Chong that was a small
way wow wow wait sorry was he was your
he was your what your bunk me you shared
a bunk was Tommy chongs well I played
tennis three hours a day and I'd write
for maybe 12 End quotes and here's the
thing Jordan Belfort is far from the
first rich person to pay for a more
luxurious prison sentence you see luxury
prisons are a very real thing it's baked
into the American justice system and
you're not gonna believe how deep it
runs stay dangerous subscribe for more
and this is an inside look at the luxury
prisons of the Rich and Famous
thank you
[Music]
if you want to get rich like these
people then you need to start building a
team behind you growing up poor my dad
filed taxes by himself to save money he
was adamant about investing himself and
not asking for help and he was always
super proud of it but as I started
meeting more rich people I realized that
they have a totally different mindset
rich people spare no expense on
accountants lawyers and financial
advisors to do all the stuff for them so
they can just focus on what they're good
at while leaving all the minutia to the
experts but finding the right experts is
hard which is where money pickle comes
in money pickle allows you to book a
free video call with just a few clicks
and then you'll get matched with one of
their certified financial planners or
fiduciaries who are ready to give you
personalized advice on what they would
do if they were in your shoes trust me
I've tried goaling answers to Super
specific Financial questions before and
it's really stressful you get
conflicting answers and I can't tell you
how many times I would have loved to
have been able to jump on a call with
someone who could just give me the
answers but now you can win money pickle
so click the link below and book a call
now there's a ton of tons to choose from
so you're not gonna have trouble finding
a ton of fits your schedule thanks to
moneypako for being the paid sponsor of
this video
remember Elizabeth Holmes she was once
dubbed the world's youngest self-made
female billionaire but then it turned
out that her blood testing company
theranos was a complete lie and that she
has windowed around 700 million dollars
from investors in the process Elizabeth
Holmes she founded this startup theranos
but Elizabeth Holmes's claims turned out
to be a 9 billion dollar fabrication it
was a scam she's a fraudster
[Music]
well after almost a decade she recently
finally got sentenced for her crimes
Elizabeth Holmes was sentenced today to
11 and a quarter years in prison this is
her punishment for four counts of
criminal fraud in January a jury found
her guilty of defrauding investors and
theranos the blood testing startup that
she ran Elizabeth Holmes had made the
same mistake as Jordan Belfort she got
caught scoring over rich people instead
of the poor Elizabeth Holmes lost her
final bid to stay out of prison while
she appeals her conviction a court today
denied her motion to remain free it's
now up to a judge to decide when homes
will have to report to prison and now
she was going to prison for him she
walked into federal prison in Texas at 1
pm today wearing jeans a sweatshirt and
sneakers inside Elizabeth Holmes handed
over her clothes and got a standard
issue prison jumpsuit in return a
uniform she is scheduled to wear for the
next 11 years of her life Case Closed
Justice served right well not really
because Elizabeth Holmes didn't go to
any ordinary prison that the average
pleb would get sent to for possessing
weed for example nope Elizabeth was sent
to one of the cushiest lowest security
prison camps in the U.S the federal
prison camp of Bryan Texas
just imagine no barbed wire fences or
barred Windows to keep the inmates
locked up you have a lower staff to
inmate ratio which means Elizabeth
doesn't have to worry about prison
guards breathing down her neck all day
imagine instead of being surrendered by
harder and violent criminals you're
surrounded by other wealthy white collar
offenders who are deemed special enough
to serve the time at Brian you'll be
allowed to wear your wedding band during
your stay and you'll have the
opportunity to volunteer work or even
take classes about things like business
skills or foreign languages and when
you're not working you can play sports
go to religious Services watch TV or
just relax and every weekend and holiday
you'll be allowed to see your children
and family one attorney said that the
Bryan federal prison camp is quote like
heaven compared to other prisons it's a
tranquil place where you can repay your
debt back to society in peace it's so
tranquil that other celebrities have
stayed here as well like how a cast
member from The Real Housewives is also
serving time for fraud there Elizabeth
is at the same prison as Jen Shaw from
The Real Housewives of Salt Lake City
this morning I spoke to Jen's attorney
Justin paperni do you think there's a
chance that her and Elizabeth will run
into each other there's a guarantee if
they're going to run into one another
and there's also going to be an
understanding amongst them so for that
reason I suspect they'll connect they
may become friend and guess what
Elizabeth's original sentence has
already been reduced theranos founder
who was convicted of fraud just had her
sentence reduced Elizabeth Holmes who
was sentenced to 11 and a half years in
prison will now spend just over nine
years in prison
[Music]
foreign
celebrities commit crimes just like
regular people but they aren't treated
in the same way when they're caught all
the way from the arrest of prison their
entire experience is completely
different first our celebrities don't
have to be in jail most of the time
because they can almost always afford
the bail amounts while poor people can
spend years sitting in jail awaiting a
trial if they can't afford their bail
celebrities are usually hit with way
lighter sentences compared to non-famous
people Lindsay Lohan was sentenced to
just one day in prison for possession of
hard drugs and a DUI but in actuality
she ended up serving exactly 84 minutes
before being released so she has to go
to jail for a day so just do the day
just just make or serve the day right no
of course not 84 minutes I mean you
think if your name is what it is rather
than Lindsay Lohan and you get two DUI
convictions and you got cocaine on you
both times I mean you wanna talk about
racing we're talking about racing before
let's say a black guy gets pulled over
here in California here in La okay in
South Central okay and he's got cocaine
on him for the second time and his
second DUI conviction you think he
spends 84 minutes in jail come on man
not in this day and age
usually people go to jail for years for
these types of charges and if
celebrities ever do serve hard time in
prison they're given crazy privileges
like room 7021 this is a private Suite
in the Los Angeles County Jail that's
been home to lots of misbehaving
celebrities O.J Simpson lived there for
nearly a year Robert Downey Jr spent a
few months in that room after a drug
conviction Sean Penn Kelsey Grammer and
Tommy Lee from the band Motley Crew all
enjoyed their stay in room 7021 and I
know it doesn't look like much but this
is the penthouse suite of Prisons it's
totally private and bigger than the
other dorm style rooms it's clean it has
no graffiti there's a 9x9 window to look
out of and get some natural sunlight the
room even has an ensuite sink toilet and
phone and the best part is that
celebrities never have to interact with
all those regular prisoners out in the
general population they don't have to
worry about dropping the soap and they
never have to endure the disgusting
conditions that the other prisoners are
forced to live in in the LA County
Prison that the conditions are
deplorable and the inmates are really
suffering shocking pictures from inside
the Inmate Reception Center in downtown
L.A the jail is overflowing it's full
and overflowing inmates chained to
chairs sleeping on concrete floors Dirty
Toilets dirty rooms I saw a man change
to a chair but laying down on the
concrete floor in a pile a puddle of his
own urine today the ACLU asked a federal
judge for an emergency order to improve
conditions at the downtown LA facility
jail overcrowding means the newly
arrested or held in the Reception Center
for long periods of time but what if
you're not famous what if you just have
money
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s in Southern California a small number
of convicted criminals have the choice
of ditching regular jail and opting for
an upgrade The Marshall Project which
covers the U.S justice system worked
with the Los Angeles Times to
investigate pay to State jails they
uncovered a list of alarming cases where
rich felons were able to score better
digs for a simple flat nightly fee you
can avoid all the downsides of prison
and Justice even worse for the most
heinous of crimes what we did find is
that there were a lot of people that
participate in these programs over 3 500
that we could identify in a five-year
period and the vast majority did it for
DUI convictions that made up 67 percent
of the people who participated 13 were
driving violations but we did find a
small subsection about four and a half
percent of people who are convicted of
crimes that included violence threats of
violence or sex crimes it has amenities
you might find at a hotel but this is
not a tree it's a jail we've had lawyers
we've had doctors we've had Catholic
priests it's called a pay to stay jail
and for criminals who have money there
are several dozen that offer a way to
avoid the often violent gang-ridden Los
Angeles County Jail take Alan warzo for
example Alan got charged for forcibly
doing stuff to a girl that he went on a
few dates with it was his second time
getting charged for the same crime and
now he was gonna face repercussions so
Alan was sent to a year in jail but
instead of going to the sketchy County
Jail Alan paid a hundred dollars a night
to go to a nice private jail that's
right for the price of a cheap hotel
Alan got a clean safer stay and it even
came with amenities like a real hotel
his room had a brand new bed the
facility had flat screen TVs and there
was even a computer room for Ellen to
use as he pleased but that nightly rate
does add up quickly by the time he
serves six months of his year-long
sentence Allen had paid over eighteen
thousand dollars a day in the upgraded
jail but if you think about it that's 3K
a month which is about the same price
you would pay for a nice apartment in an
expensive city so if you do have the
money saved up it is definitely a
no-brainer as one pay to stay inmate who
was charged with horrible crimes against
a 14 year old girl put it in County Jail
you're verbally abused and physically
abused by everybody I didn't want to
spend one day in there I mean who does
but since it is pricey these plushy
presents are usually only occupied by
the rich so the most expensive is 251
the cheapest one we found was twenty
five dollars that's a night yes per
night but it's typically between about
100 and 150 a night one dude got into a
freeway car accident while he was drunk
killing one of his passengers ended up
spending 72 000 to do all this time in a
private jail that is seven thousand
dollars more than the tuition of Yale
University
[Music]
now it may seem unfair that rich people
experience a completely different
justice system than the poor those who
are wealthy are able to upgrade their
facilities and stay in nicer jails than
those who are poor who might have
committed the same exact crime it may
seem unfair that you can commit the same
exact crime as some other guy but he
gets to play tennis during his sentence
and you have to worry about not dropping
the soap in yours I get convicted of
something and as part of the plea deal I
say I'll pay a hundred bucks a night
please don't send me to this more
violent facility send me to this safer
place that they've got empty rooms so I
can see what could be positive about
that but the big negative is it doesn't
sound very fair if you don't have the
money then that's not an option you can
take advantage of I think that's the
question it really raises is that it's
not so much that people can I mean
obviously the point of the story is that
people can pay for a better jail stay
well it also it raises the question of
why do we send people who don't have
money into dangerous and often very
dirty situations where they might be
physically assaulted they might get very
ill the health care is notoriously bad
so I think that's something to think
about you know that's because it is
unfair no they weren't happy about that
you know they felt that they that the
person should have gone to a type of
jail that they imagined there was one
example in the story in particular of a
guy who actually spent a lot of time in
jail in prison in his younger years and
he was stabbed by someone and that
person did a pay to stay and he was just
kind of remarking that you know I never
even knew that existed that's not
something I would have never been able
to do because I don't we didn't I didn't
have the money to even afford an
attorney for myself so that was a really
kind of Stark example but think about it
this way isn't it nice that there is
this other option that if you really
wanted to you can make more money to
ensure that if you do ever get sent to
prison you can afford to stay in one of
these nicer prisons because let's be
real there is no way American prisons
are ever going to be reformed so that
all of them are nice and cozy and safe
as the ones we went over in this video
so at least now you know that there is
this option should you still need it
because although money will not buy you
happiness it's sure can buy you a
comfier present sentence
all the examples we want over in this
video are stories of people who had
money but did not have influence until
they went to prison a more comfy prison
but a prison nonetheless but you want to
know who completely shattered this rule
O.J Simpson oh yes OJ may have had the
money he may have had the cultural
influence but he did not have the kind
of influence with the powers that be
like what we talked about earlier and
yet he still got acquitted he never even
had to look at the inside of a prison
cell but how how did OJ get away with
murder when there was so much evidence
against them when we expose it all in
our new documentary on our new channel
how to get away with it now you can
watch right now by clicking the card on
the screen and tense it has to do with
how there was a second killer involved
in the OJ killings that somehow slept
right underneath the Public's
Consciousness to this day click the card
on the screen to watch now
[Music]